hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to portal 2 with Sean
leech also known as Patrick hey that's
good that's good how you doing good good
ok so actually funny thing when you pick
this up I noticed that the door didn't
close so we can just walk right through
and have a cube
we're probably gonna break the game oh
no no no all right fine then I thought
we get smell of home here
hey I'm not full of human fear I'm
actually brave I've faced a lot of
horror games you have no idea ok so we
this is a conundrum uh that doesn't seem
to help anybody okay I need a holding
our button down
no I don't think so just yet but what we
do see over there um no we I have no
idea what to do yet so we're still
figuring this out ok so the basic
principle is that we need to get up
there the both of us need to get up
there so there has to be a laser I need
to find out what this button does oh
that's what that button does
ok so what's interesting is there's so
much waves to put your portal we
literally made a ton of white areas yeah
there are just an enormous amount of
white areas so there's a button over
here that'll release a disintegration
wall that allows us to jump down and
gain some momentum here and I can't even
press my look button through it
I can't even press my look button at all
anymore why is my look button broken my
look bug doesn't work you what the hell
they're suppressing our look buttons
that's so [ __ ] ok and right here's
where the lasers are supposed to go okay
so if you look down there that button
the big red button it releases the
disintegration wall down there so I need
you to go down there and press that
button ok now you can let go of the
button because now no matter what so
long as I keep this you can jump through
these without the portal disappearing so
now I'm gonna take
uh wait let me take your portal back
here okay
this is good okay so now um get yourself
back up like just create your red portal
on the wall beside you and then walk up
because you already have a portal up
there okay so walk up okay so now stand
on the edge and be ready to jump down
through it because I just put a portal
here so that you can launch yourself up
there so John right here
yeah jump whenever you're ready all
right trust me
it's cool we okay alright so there's no
boxes up there even in the room where
all the things are are there any boxes
and anything no don't no way to get
something as if we both press the but at
the same time and it will give us some
yeah yeah but what's in that room the
white room with the robots what's in
there that's another laser thing I think
there's something on the wall goodness
that's a laser emitter I believe okay so
we both need to get up there but the
only problem is that I can't get up
there by myself it's the only real issue
there's no portable walls up there right
none unless I go through here and the
robots can get to me
yeah we don't need that oh there's a
button oh there's a button that drops a
box right there Oh duh goes it's there
going back and forth okay so with one
box so that's okay okay so you can get
down now because now I mean we have to
grab it midair yes we do
so what we need to do is we need to get
you momentum because pressing the big
red button there flattens out the the
portable the movable portable thing that
launched you up so if you press the big
red button see how it makes it flat so
we just need to be able to get up there
from that and we can do that or maybe
now that wouldn't be high enough now we
need to do we need to do it this way so
we need
all right so I need you first off I need
you over here to press this button
actually first off I need to go place
this portal okay you stay there stay
there okay so I need to place this there
so that needs to be there okay so all
right so now yeah okay press the button
and I'm gonna put my portal there again
all right
okay so bad portals there all right so
come back up here because you need to
leave this place a different way than
you came from it so instead of jumping
through there because I have to be on
that big red button before that happens
or more specifically you have to be on
that no that doesn't makes that care
Mixon okay yes um oh no no wait wait
come back okay I know what to do okay I
understand what to do because to do this
jump pad no I I know exactly what to do
okay so watch this all right so I'm
coming back through there alright so
press the big red button again okay big
red button breast okay so I can just
jump through here like this and I go up
here and then you you can get up on the
other platform and then just jump
through my portals cuz they won't go
away jump right through you got it and
now we're both up here now we can both
press these buttons just be careful are
three to one point and we have another
cube and this cube can be used to either
laser yeah will or more specifically can
be used to get the other button right
now those fun yeah so get over to the
other side and then you can jump through
my portals again to grab that thing
alright same thing I did before yeah
yeah and then like it went down here and
go through yes that'll be totally
acceptable all right now just jump
through my portal and you should be able
to eventually it'll coordinate
hopefully there you go well no oh live
link grab it
move there we go now you're a champion
okay so now we just need to angle this
so drop that box down there's a little
black square down there drop it so it's
pointing against the portal wall yeah
there we go and then just have it
straight in there drop it down okay make
a portal there where it's pointing ah
okay so when you come back just um hit
the springboard on the right side when
you come out hit the springboard and
then you'll pop right through and then
we can do this okay
now put a portal down there just without
going down there there we go
okay and now on the other side over here
without falling down you can put a
portal wall right there there we go see
ya alright okay so this is good so
webster got killer bots we still do have
that that is a problem so we need to
take this off of there I can put this
one there um let's see so that needs to
stay there that is the main problem
right now so we need to get ah okay I
love the pink heart thank you I worked
very hard at it so we need to get in
that room without dying that's the
hardest issue okay so forget that laser
for now we'll come back to that laser uh
get over to the other side again and
then jump through my portal to get up
there or actually no we both need to get
up there so just drop that um go over to
the other side again and we're gonna
both do this
whoosh good luck thank you stay over
there for just a hot second alright okay
so the interesting thing is there are
huh so there is a laser trap in there
but that means we have to get a laser in
there somehow and that is really weird
should I jump through your portal
because if you go through dare yours is
gonna disappear see I can't get in that
room unless I have a box blocking my way
that would work oh no the box would be
destroyed as soon as it goes through
there huh this will I would die if I go
through there but maybe only one of us
needs to go through there and get to the
end so come through my portal jump
through get up here with me okay
so what's gonna happen here is I'm going
to protect you I am going to sacrifice
myself so that you can get to those
bastards and take them out before they
kill us both
okay we're gonna flank up the left side
staying on the left side you stay right
behind me I will take their bullets for
you okay
all right yes to one okay I'm not mad I
bleed you but if I go on the left and
you go on the right then we can make it
through we can do this we can get past
them let's just do this again go press
the button we can do this so this time
I'm gonna go on the left and then you're
gonna go around the right flank and both
will win this actually no I'm gonna go
wide right I should I need to get over
there one second odds let me hang on
hang in two seconds so I'm gonna go wide
on the left and then you go wide around
no I'm gonna go right you go left
whoof anyway now we got no portal down
here there we go
shh-shh-shh alright so go through your
portal like the same way yeah very good
what come on of course not enough
momentum you did a thing different than
the thing you've done every time do you
really going oh maybe this one's gonna
work yeah actually I did
Wow then then I am so sad okay so this
time I'm gonna go I'm gonna go wide
right you flank right off the left side
get as close to the wall as you can or
is it are you going left like I'm going
right you go left
I know I made this very clear don't even
pretend to be confused about my
directions all right so I'm gonna go all
right are you ready get as close to the
wall as possible you need as much space
okay I just let them let them go to
sleep okay ready
what 3 2 1 oh they didn't like that oh
that almost worked because they went up
for me I know you and I know but it's
fine I almost made it through I almost
made it through we can do that because
fine and Mark tried to take me out first
that's that yeah pretty much
and it almost worked but we'll do it
together the Simon buy together I mean
you'll probably die okay press the
button again yeah get over there thanks
babe
all right I guess I'm officially known
as the button press oh yes that's good
job you do impressing them buttons yeah
okay so
so ready for me to get up there yeah so
as soon as you get up there we're gonna
press those suckers like no tomorrow
okay much i doin that's distracting for
whoever gets there first ready 3 2 1 oh
ok that's more they hit me first and
then they immediately went to you so
they only got to go against one of us
first three two one I'm going look at me
look at me look at me look at me look at
me
what don't go is like don't go the way
I'm going
don't goes away but obviously that
wouldn't mean the same exact path I took
cuz you're gonna get hit by the bullets
that they're shooting at me in all
honesty I have no idea if it's gonna
work and frankly I don't think it will
but we're trying now if this is gonna be
a problem I'd be the distraction okay
fine by me fine fine by me this seems to
be clear that they like shooting me they
do indeed do that okay so I'm gonna
count three two one you go then I'll
follow immediately after okay all right
three two one go come up they went for
me why I have one other idea yeah what's
up there's two white walls in there one
behind them and we're on the left side
there suppose I have enough time to get
through there before they kill us I just
had another idea I know I know
I know what to do oh I know what to do
oh I know I made it to the button I made
it to the button just before they killed
me and the button opens up the wall
which means that one of us can carry
this through okay let's get up there
again we need to get up there but I'm
gonna bring this block with us this time
you're going to run in there straight
for the button you go for the button
nothing else you hit that button as soon
as you hit it I as soon as you hit it I
go right through this with this box okay
make sense one last question yeah what's
up did you see that
is there a white wall on the left side
that I could portal through before they
kill me then I can portal
dammit God okay I'm fine it's fine
uh no it that's actually farther than
the button is I I know we can make it to
the button we cannot make it to that so
flip-flop go on the right side okay this
way I can see let them settle and then
on your go just go for that button
hundred percent straight for that button
three two one
oh so close
oh no the is hard just try to skirt
right around that corner as close as you
can and go super fast
ah so close okay that's not gonna work
sprinting Adams not gonna work the
teamworks not gonna work it's gotta be
another way
oh oh oh my god this was so simple
oh we were doing so bad oh my God look
at this right there right there oh my
god
are they both dead yes well there you go
then now you can go through oh man now
we both need to go oh wow that looks bad
for me oh that is so bad whew okay it's
like for you it's like several three two
well I mean I ever evidence tags okay
now I'm gonna go through Oh boom
okay now that you're up here before you
go through my portal before you do make
sure that the laser is going to the
right place
okay go through there and get on the
button okay now I'm going to leave this
here excuse me pardon me switching spots
alright so leave that there
wait leave that right there
okay now that's there alright so yeah
the main suitable yeah the main problem
was that
at UH the laser okay now you can go back
down and uh portal the laser where it
needs to be I think I supposed to place
your portals inside there before you
walk out well I'm still on the button
you're right you're 100% right okay but
actually yeah this is super easy let me
let me do that here just walk through my
portal there walk through my portal
there
easy peasy easy peace okay now that
you're up there I can just put this one
here and then put the other portal right
there and we got it yeah fine yes
oh man oh there's more there's more
oh my guess more okay we don't have time
for more we're all out of time for now
but so this is the last episode that I'm
gonna be recording a portal to with
Patrick unless you guys really want more
let me know down in the comments below
and be sure to check out his channel
Schad leeches name any final words
Patrick had a great time with mark
playing this so you do want to yeah hard
it out yeah definitely
but anyway best of luck to you you on
your channel thank you everybody for
watching out there and as always we will
see you in the next video don't ever
interrupt my outro don't you ah ha 3
hell's to the yeah